مشاهدينا بالعوده للخبر العاجل الذي
نقلناه قبل قليل حيث نذكر بالاعتداء الذي
تعرض له مراسل الجزيره منتصر نصار في قريه
دورا بالخليل بالضفه الغربيه على يد قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وقد اعلنت قوات
الاحتلال اعتدت عليه على مراسل الجزيره
وعلى المصور المرافق له بالضرب ما ادى الى
اصابه المراسل بردود كما صادروا المعدات
التي كان يحملها
ينضم الينا الان مراسل الجزيره عبر الهاتف
من مستشفى الخليل منتصر نصار اهلا بك
منتصر الف لا باس عليك وعلى الزميل
المصور ما الذي
حدث نعم عبد السلام يعني نحن كنا في موقع
اطلاق النار الذي جرى في منطقه وادي
الشجني بمدينه دوره جنوب محافظه الخليل
وكنا قد خرجنا برساله مباشره في نشره
الاخبار السابقه من الموقع ونقلنا تفاصيل
وصوره ما يجري انتهينا من البث المباشر في
النشره
وقررنا انا والزميل المصور ان ناخذ مكانا
اخر نعت ل سطح احد المنازل كي نتمكن من
التقاط صور افضل للموقع و ونحن على الهواء
مباشره قوات الاحتلال جاءت باتجاهنا ولم
تتكلم معنا ولم تحدثنا بشيء ولم تقل لنا
ان المكان ممنوع التصوير فيه ولم تبدي ايه
اي شيء يعني هي كانت في دوريه وجنود مشا
تقدموا الينا ونحن على الهواء مباشره ولم
يحدثونا بشيء وبالتالي اعتقدنا ان عملنا
متاح في تلك المنطقه كما قلت اعتلينا اصطح
احد المنازل تفاجانا بعد حوالي خمس دقائق
باقتحام قوه كبيره من جنود الاحتلال الذين
اعتلوا سطح المنزل الذي كنا نتواجد عليه
وبداوا بضربنا ضربا مبرحا دون ان دون ان
يعطوا لنا مجال حتى للحديث كنت اقول لهم
اننا صحفيون وان هذا عملنا الصحفي لم
يسمحوا لنا حتى بالحديث انهالوا علينا
بالضرب المبرح قاموا
بخلع الخوذه والدرع الواقي الذي نرتديه
قاموا بتكسير الكاميرا قبل ان يقوموا
بمصادرتها صادروا جهاز البث تي فيو صادروا
اجهزتنا الخاصه اجهزه التليفون الخاصه بي
وبالضمير المصور احمد عمر و قامت تفتيشنا
مره اخرى بعد الاعتداء علينا بالضرب وقبل
ان تنسحب من الموقع قامت
بتكسير اللوجو الخاص بقناه الجزيره في
الميكروفون الذي كنا نحمله قاموا بالقائه
عن سطح المنزل وتكسير اللوجو بشكل كامل
واعتدوا علينا ايضا مره اخرى ووجهوا لنا
رسائل تحذير قبل ان ينسحبوا من المكان
وكما قلت صادروا الكاميرا التي تعرضت
لتكفير جهاز البث وا اجهزتنا الخاصه ايضا
و تعرضنا كما ذكرنا لضرب مبرح طبعا نقلتنا
س ياره اسعاف بلديه دوه قبل قليل الى
مستشفى دوره الحكومه نتواجد اه المستشفى
تعرضنا الحقيقه نزم المصور لعدد من الردود
في انحاء متفرقه من اجساد منطقه الراس
والقدم واليدين ونحن نتلقى العلاج الان في
مستشفى دوره الحكومي في جنوب مدينه الخليف
الف لا باس عليما بطبيعه الحال